[Music]
so what I'm going to present today is
our my personal journey on lipid
research it started almost 10 years ago
in particular the journey in Blackrock
that where I start to run this project
three years ago and the topic of the
quiddity is a typical financial problem
that is very difficult to solve that's
why the papers and research illiquidity
they arrived pretty late in the industry
and in standard methodology and because
of sparse data because of all or sparse
annoys a date or multidimensionality so
it's typical type of problem the way
machine learning can help okay so what
I'm going to show to you is first of all
what is the AI for us so what I think is
the right uses for us in finance in
particular for mindful specific project
publish in learning AI e
where why and when in finance in
particular liquidity the problem of
Antin for performance but we aware about
black boxes and asthma I represent some
model overview in the model we already
implemented and give you two other lab
models that we are testing in the lab ok
so a little bit of names so for me
machine learning is making sense of a
large data set
recognizing complex part in a data and
is be able to account for non-linearity
get rid of other mathematical
assumptions like assume a linearity of
some behavior some features or normality
all these games that the typical
mathematical assumption they were done
in what they call con finest 1.0 to me
machine learning 313 used a war machine
learning and AI so far my machine is not
intelligent it's just a machine the
concurrency auto data and extract
impactor in those data
and some of these factors behavior are
good for me as features in the job of
forecasting liquidity now a security
level portfolio level or them shelita
risk whatever we do okay there are some
cool names here this deserved the one
dear to me because I start too many
years ago to approach to liberating a
lot cluster analysis in this type of
problem
pattern recognition what is say a
regression because now everybody thinks
are ashamed to say regression no we
still use regression and I am not
ashamed that last quarter we're allowed
free modeling production to base on
machine learning approaches and one was
linear aggression with two variables
does his job no shame in doing that okay
just so I am a guy looking for
innovation I am dreaming to be able to
four to build for the PDT divorced a
serious deep learning model
interpretability is not the problem I'm
going to mention to you but if you have
something that does its job and is a
simple interpretable model to variables
in regression
take it okay now machine learning is not
that one so it's not a robot in
particularly finance think about finance
we we have a fiduciary role to our
client so I'm building model providing
analytics to perform manager or a trader
and this guy is making business decision
with other people money okay so we
cannot use black boxes thing that we
cannot understand so for me machine
learning is not a chasm of scenario
maybe one day but not now and there will
be enough hole during that day when is
gonna happen and when you recognize
pattern in a financial data you can
recognize that pattern so there is a
correlation between the interest rates
and eight of the fetcher so you know
better than me that if you plug these
features in a machine whatever is
regression this will be significant
features so now you pretend to know the
next eight or definitely dead the
fetcher you are claiming to forecast the
interest rates so you must be careful
about
this type of pattern that the machine
would include in particular machine in
the case of deep learning will use this
pattern without telling to you okay just
set up the stage right when the middle
between myth and reality application
machine learning in finance explainable
AI xai people loves acronym this is a
new cramming that I mean I start to see
these acronyms few years ago and we we
must enable the user to understand what
the algorithms does so basically this is
a beautiful chart struck by a
presentation done by by DARPA but is
beautiful to represent the function
between S Pen ability and the lonely
performance so clearly we are now moving
in particular in our case in this area
the dream is to go to deep learning but
we still have something to do before
going to deep learning but for sure we
are able to prove that traditional or
machine learning methodology if we call
random forest machine learning and they
do I can add very very cannot important
improve performance but different now
that we have a lot of data to turn the
model ok so this picture is our
guidelines for our daily job when we do
in the lab we start to push on
innovation okay so our learn our journey
on machine learning applied to liquidity
and and again I was a few years ago and
I start to work on liquidity people in
finance here are no better than me but
develop people are working on fixing and
that but about 10 years ago there were
no data ok trace was a system where
people were trace data trace data we are
reported for us corporate one highly
noisy no competitors parent we kept
etc and there was nothing in Europe
almost nothing in Europe nothing in
emerging market equity you a doubt of
that about highly noisy and there was at
the practice about model to forecast
liquidity of a security so you have a
situation where we have a lot of debt
highly noisy we need to stock senior
from this assemble noisy data or you
have entire market well we have a decent
amount of data only on the small part of
the market and it come out with a
forecast for the rest of the disability
in the market so the principal here
every trader a very powerful manager
will do exactly taking a taking a bond
for example put in the bond in excess
start to put in excess features download
by information provider then based on
his experience we start to define the
list of similar bond based on some
features rating Kapaun amount of
standing etc and trying to back up give
us every sense of price in the liquidity
of the target bond is that to evaluate
to look in similar bonds the video thing
of machine learning class Tirana is
random for that basically more or less
do that thing and you can scale ultimate
eyes that thing okay so that one I think
was the forced adventure now what we do
here this is the description of the
entire overall project so because of
this the problem of estimating liquidity
the quiz it arrived very late and the
liquidity arrived if you look best
practice for a credit model default
probability model we can agree or not
agree with those model but there are
plenty of model from the 80s deep
mathematical model very compressed model
in liquidity there is almost nothing a
couple of paper almost play with the
same three concept a back and forth is
that because no data etc and so people
was keeping liquidity little bit outside
there is management process I do market
risk do credit risk I do prefer the
musician who tracking error and then on
the side I try to figure it out to add a
sense what is liquidity my portfolios
now regulators gave me a job because
they were eight or ten years ago on the
backside and the only safe side force
then on the on the by side they start to
push for people to adopt liquidity
measurement metrics to control equities
in particular Blackrock decided to I
have a more broader vision so really
embedded liquidity in the risk
management process many years ago when I
was trying to convince my former company
to invest in a nanda step or research I
was mentioning if you think about value
to risk widely used by everybody since
30 years maybe 25 years is not
necessarily the right risk management
but create a baseline to which comprises
people portfolio manager his manager
talk based on some numbers okay
I want to the grass how good or bad is
batteries but the risk create this link
and if you think embedded in vegetarian
there is one crazy assumption that you
have studied the series of the price out
of each to generate your distribution so
every single position in the price 10 10
to 20 days ago
you coulda sold that day your entire
position immediately in the market at
that price that's simply not true
because when you want to unwind a
position then the unit will beside the
venue decide how you want to trade sell
this position if the position is big
even at the cost okay so do people have
to become with the concept about the
debility adjusted by eateries okay so
this was a way to plug liquidity from
the beginning into the management
process so what we have to do what to do
a gigantic infrastructure and
fortunately for my job every company
went I was hired to build models I start
to build models after 18 month when tea
for our mouth the first three years was
building databases cleaning the data
going around the company and under for
and county for data the data were and
they're convinced the big guys to have
funding for the data
whoo narrator together so was necessary
to create this environment this is that
what what what we did here so for the
quiddity there was a necessity to do to
unify the date already aware having
internal data from a from Blackrock
external vendor porches other external
information crunching this with a high
performance computing this case we use
of GPUs we create our source environment
and where necessary based on machine
learning this we call this absolutely
our liquidity vault okay we have all
this magic data to build a liquidity
models then we go here in the job we
want to build a transaction cost we want
to have simulate that because of our
utilization rebalance in whatever we
want to sell a specific volume of of a
disposition can be borned inequity
whatever we want to have an idea how
much gonna cost us and if we we wait
more time or less time how the price
going to change so we want to build this
liquidity transaction cost official
phase then we want to aggregate the
portfolio manager as I prefer you level
the liquidity and this is tricky because
the concept of correlation of liquidity
the typical way people they are they
aggregate for for the level is trickier
and if you start to sell a bond in a
portfolio and you have bond the same
issue in the same portfolio when you go
to say the second bond may be the beauty
profile of this bond is changed because
the first said you did so here I think
there is a better way to approach this
problem I'm gonna mention to you then
the other side the liquidity in that for
us a manager is very important assuming
that my portfolio liquid or including
controller liquidity I can receive
redemption from my clients on the fund
so I need to be able to unwind the
position at a reasonable cost because
I'm controlling the queries to give it
cash back to the people that are
redeeming the fun and not too hard the
people stay in the fund okay so I
discovered that the redemption if
rational risk is one of the most
difficult process whenever the
think you know be able to forecast that
in this particular fund I would have
this outflows next week or next month is
a very difficult problem because depends
from market condition specifically the
syncretic information of the fund
behavior of people depends from if the
fund is widely used from for pension
fund for other company if there is a
moment with a lot of people who retire
we didn't have structure outflows in the
endeavor so there is so many things to
account in the fund so basically here is
the case where we try to pin to pin the
message with the linear aggression
gradient boosting machine last
regression but the only way with where
we found some decent performance was
using narrow networks okay then we plug
we plot this so the iniquitous a little
Albie has been that beginning we plug
this into portfolio to musician and our
dream is to write to this concept well
we have this is the portfolio actually
is the chart but is a real simulation
area fund where you have cash the cost
and you want to allow the attraction air
or if you want to sell pro rata or
allowed the portfolio to optimize the
ability profile you want to basically to
control the risk
so basically try to have the highest
possible cash raised with a lower
possible cost you want to try to be to
be sorry of the core okay and then when
you have this you can finally make
everybody happy you serve with one
centralized engine portfolio
construction training support liquid
adjusted risk what I mentioned before
and regulatory reporting okay and we are
for some things we are in a good stage
of the project to serve these guys we
are still working for the coverage in
order to implement to plug into this and
optimizer in our platform okay
but this is bigger sense or the broader
project that we are doing on ability to
to honor my guest so be the Google
people that they kindly invite me here
give you sense what we are doing here we
are using the cloud we are actually we
were the
most user in Blackrock my team of the
Google Cloud there are many other people
using the cloud now but we are basically
using the cloud for proof of concept and
then where I found the benefit so I have
a couple of guys very expert in machine
learning but they have their job
liquidity my job is not building a
Burnett to remain job is providing the
create analytics so sometimes we don't
have the bandwidth to do experiment and
having this guy be able to experiment
him bringing up to 40 plus GPUs the
trainer to train a neural network or
using the I CPUs instance with the 94-96
portal that were available enable us to
speed up our PC process fraggin EDS bad
idea so saving time or actually start to
investigate in invest in this area okay
now this is the role of machine learning
in our search I try to solve the problem
that to attack machine learning first of
all we are doing ml on small on media
data set for a moment we are expanding
now tool a data set and I'm mentioning
this because you will not see here deep
learning model because by definition to
do deep learning you had in to have a
messy data set okay so here we are
working with more immediate asset based
on for transaction cost Redemption at
risk third double volume actual was our
big successful story of last year so to
one component as action cost you must be
able to forecast the t+ wanted double
volume of specific Q zip and we found a
lot of benefit in a model level in
machine learning and security similarity
the the thing the concept of an
introduced
machine learning tools we use primary
rubberised in regression and forest
dragon boost in trees
despite we in the lab now in the lab we
have a narrow network presentation of
some of this model number for the user
suspect so the machine learn the narrow
net implementation despite they are
improving the performance respect to the
random falls but not crazy because that
isatis t
medium-sized where the problem
interpretability so we prefer for a
moment to roll out a random forest
approach and respect to the narrow
nettle where we are keeping this in the
lab ort resources on this I will try as
you know synthesis is not the best way
to reach audiences I talked a lot but I
will try to save five minutes for Q&A at
the end
now here Hendra and Roy to see how
typically problem we need to solve B
than a spread straight line useless
because that to you that you have the
same cost independently format you want
to serve the theory is a tip every every
transaction cost model in every paper
more or less is using a sub linear
approach in this difficult function or
you can spend hours to recalibrate the -
menendez 0.6 0.4 but this approach those
model are very poor because the blue
points are more or less more or less how
the data will look like very noisy but
actually the cost goes down for when you
try super small volume then is almost
flat around the banana spread then we
start to spike up and when Spike ups
typically you don't tell a lot of
salvation I'm talking about free for
observation per bond in the quarter so
how can you fit a model in that in that
area so the real cool is the green one
the theory says try to calibrate the
model using the red one and now we are
we think that never approach deep
learning we can help a lot a lot in the
future to actually go in nonparametric
and going to fit much better and for
class much better this cool ok there is
typically the 3d problem so I want to
have a model that together can account
for transit for the slippage of the
curve in function of time so now if I
have a cost of 10 basis points selling
10 million if I wait more time I will be
able to lower the cost so that they
differ the problem people people are
trying to solve and the similarity
constant is very important because it's
something that you
the count when you build the liquidity
models bond one bond shoe assuming that
this is the good call
stay with me now I'm selling something
in bond one eventually and when I'm I'm
gonna ship the kuru bond shoe so when I
gonna go to seed to set the bond shoe I
have a different transaction cost goal
and this to us is can be attacked this
problem using security similarity making
an inkless between securities
google has the knowledge graph similar
concept about this making a making a
link between entities in this case
security in general or bonds now the
data first of all let me go back this
equation could be you use you need you
have observed cost and you are aiming to
tiny model based on this cost okay
people coming from other sector is why I
mean I asked the question before they
feel okay I have up in historical series
of something that I observe that's the
Bible
that's true and now I can tell you my
mother whatever model it is in finance
I'm sorry
the stationers like this to provoke you
understanding this concept here I did
this is a transaction cost fool if the
current function of volume trader banana
spread ad adversary volume in other
features the independent variable is
this called implementation shortfall is
the differential between the trader that
I did and dimensional price so the
market was at betty's devil I traded
this level this level this definition is
the cost that I got in the moment I look
I you look the cost I train the model
and try to forecast in the future this
cost okay here is a very liquid bond
very easy
he's a telecommunication bond between
three four percent coupon
maturity 2092 and they calculate this
implementation shortfall we our trades
vessel three different information
provider everybody claiming I gave you
the right price okay look this records
so now you train whatever it is in a
regression on our network when you are
here you are in trouble because you
don't know if even which is the true so
I tell to my guys I'm sorry guys but 60%
of your job is cleaning plumbing and
cleaning data this is something that you
we have to do internally that's why this
type the application machine learning in
finance there are many reasons but the
failure to are dealing with real money
but this red this type of problem data
to train the mothers are very are often
not available or now that become
available can be very noisy but
inconsistent
okay now what we do here we this was the
permutation chauffeur that I mentioned
before so you we have our benchmark
price with the cutie tray that the
differential is our observer cost out of
which we train our model whatever
methodology we use and our our model is
defined to on many important features
this cost typically the biddin a spread
the volume forecast I I know that this
bond as hide about a level volume
whatever I wanna sell I have a lower
cost a bond with lower that the whole
body in the market if I grows closer to
this level and when I have a spy to the
cost another features and I show this
diagram because for a moment instead of
in going wild and deep learning or this
kind of stuff within the entire
transaction cost we only for one
component of the transaction cost we use
machine learning and now we are talking
the other part okay and here we use on
the forest we have an implementation in
the lab with our network with the same
problem interpretability
and this is very important because this
model now is a production it works very
well so far our customer the traders are
very happy the problem that think about
let's assume that we have the pattern
model I don't by the way but I have a
decent performance tomorrow forecast for
a specific bond a big drop drop in
tradable volume so the senior very
severe warning for our trailer
they need to do something about that or
or not kinda quarantine the bond it had
to unwind some position not that one
start to sell to implement in to
implement a strategy to Hedgehog from
this liquidity risk on this bond if I
say there is the drop of 80 percent of
the tidal volume is the big thing
next thing the guy we can ask me why and
the counter to him I have a beautiful
deep learning model I bet tested and
cool my guys as much as Mar to be the
sense people take it because this guy is
making decision trading real people
money ok that's why in our network we
can pick up some sort of
interpretability so in a random forest
we can be caps and sorted a bit a bit
now I can say to the guy I have an
example here why the model is moving its
forecast something different so only on
the transit or a value forecast where
this framework where a prime air one
network and we basically now it won't
went to much details happy to provide
you offline some details but here we
what we do here we train we try to
Toronto Forest one an empirical data
using empirical volume data and another
one based on features in absence of the
of transactional data so we are able to
leveraging that to add a gas of the
tradable volume for bond that never saw
volume a bond and never saw volume for
example doesn't mean that is in liquid
is the bond that there's no trade but
you can go to trade this bond easily or
is a signal that this bond is
untreatable ok and then we have some
concept of probability of trade so we
need we separated the model in trying to
define the probability
our problem is a probability this one's
been trade and then when is gonna trade
which is the expected volume okay and
this model so far is working pretty well
and is the one that has a never natural
parallel approach on this transaction
cost overall I tell you this said story
over the progress of this model is very
important
so we have initial model linear
regression model based on either they
data the process means very very poor
out to some performance I can tell you
only between us that the deltas and
performance this mother was one percent
so pretty low the reason why I'm putting
these dots and not the numbers because
some people in my company they warned me
listen
you going in front of Google people and
there will be a lot of non-financial
people and then you're gonna brag the
performance on the last line that in
finance is a very big number outside
finance is a ridiculous number okay or
not read about low number so just to
avoid the credibility issues with you I
hide the number so I put I've been
distorting no so the photo was very bad
when I went to intraday date I did some
work on defining battery in the
implementation short for that dimension
before the model was okay then we start
to do partitioning on the universe so we
start to separate by n cell then we
start to separate if you think we said
to do a constant of manual classes we
are marketing the universe in more
homogeneous groups and fitting the model
within each groups and you think is what
in one shot a random forest will do and
and now we are working a lot on additive
model generalized additive model
nonparametric model like random forest
and we are as well in the lab testing
never nectar this is never Network for
the entire transaction cost
so not only one component we expect that
if we turn the model of a big amount of
data the performance will be very high
I don't know yet next event you will
know how the model works so far we were
out in production this model based on
its aggressive approach based on
partition of the universe now we are
generalizing this with with cluster
analysis random forest that the next
step of so far we're at the production
is model that is using the adv
base or under forest and so far the
multiple from pretty well ok he give you
shall give you some story with evolution
now experiment
this is an example of November 2000 okay
I was my company was very lucky not to
have been in the last four years
any serious liquidity stress for me was
domination because I am nothing to train
the data on my liquidity stress okay so
I say this against the interests of my
company now I need a some bad moment so
I can verify my model otherwise
everything is good
my mother is good something like this
happened in November there was some
stress in the market but didn't run in
Kolkata bond market and we are very
happy to see that from beginning of
amber up to Thanksgiving where the
stress was very evident to manifest the
whole situation that's why we have a job
situation where portfolio manager they
were ordering okay need to unwind his
position the spine because Medina spread
is not moving and the traders say I'm
sorry but when I go to trade these guys
Bam Bam is more difficult to even higher
cost and there was this connection
between the show the concept of
liquidity doesn't depend a serial of
observable business spread can depend
from many other features so the entire
model we are able this something that
you cannot do in our network so I was
invited in acid in the I spotlight
Google to find a solution this subject
you can do a random forest this is
devolution for a group of three bonds
the issuer average behavior of the
transaction cost across November and the
transaction cost went went up a lot
whatever basis point so what we could
unwind here were very different what it
would have whined to the end of the
mouth and you see that duration time
spread was packing up as expected we
didn't spread is almost flat being
spread in one in that mouth actually
went down even even even I account
counter intuitive of 0.2 basis point so
nothing okay
but a DB was dropping and interest ring
the number of dinner ranks was dropping
so one defeats were use is just simply
count how many dinner on are
contributing this bond is a measure of
interest I know their interest on Google
people here they're gonna have a lot of
ideas about average in news is tough
road is but for a moment for us County
now many dealer answer
building a bond is an indication of
interest around this bond making
business out of this bond now this
number drops for us is a warning the
more they react to this so bananas
spread that is technically the main
driver a transaction cost wasn't moving
but other features less important a lot
of them they were moving and finally the
transaction cost were doing a good job I
did my test I claimed another one I know
I don't want any more stress in the
market because it was very painful math
forum anyway but this is that the reason
why we're doing this job so now we can
provide a signal exactly to the traders
and we can attribute this the impure
features okay idea for next step quick
very quick I mentioned to you that we
have in the lab a generalized additive
models that we try and for this
different group of market we improve the
performance of the model of 6:22 and 11%
and that's very natural is kinda fit in
nearly a submariner model different
model for every band of volumes so is
the orange curve if you remember is that
is similar to the empirical shape of the
data in the first slide I show to you
going down then up then one thing we
make guys we start soon in the lab is a
laboratory enforcement learning on the
transaction cost level and this we think
is going to be performing very very well
technically and particularly useful for
stress testing I have nothing to say to
you now because we are we need to start
were configuring the environment to do
this experiment but this is an evolution
of the transactional cost we gonna do
similarity this is our been bragging
about this and talking about this for 10
years so we have now different
methodologies to be able to define given
the first-born this case I picked up a
company born see me that bone this is
complete done by the machine so here you
can use graston Alice's can use grand
dragon boost entry you can use network
network and again if used in our network
you're gonna have interpretability
problem but we are very happy about this
and now you see that - total bond are
very similar if you start to do
santorini activity on the first one when
you go to trade to make trade on the
second one you're gonna have a different
different liquidity profile and so we
are basically defining this similarity
based on how the security are highly
connected or not there is a model we are
implementing about this so in the
similarity we have a distant based
matrix that is done we we we are testing
God using kinda [ __ ] trees and the
next we're gonna be a same super
vibrational out encoders and potentially
knowledge graph I do believe that they
knowledge the grass concept I don't know
yet
will be the answer internal methodology
tool to do this job again to honor my my
guest is about interpretability
in this case interpret it become a much
more important than other cases because
this will be used widely technically
even for portfolio construction we are
many many people were investigating but
these two paper and are undone by google
people i think is the deep mind people i
think so this is basically what we are
doing in the lab now another the title
here is redemption Oteri's the beginning
of our artificial neural network loud at
the angel because if you think about
regressive modest random forest based on
now we are to date about not petabyte of
data you can work in the internal
infrastructure and databases random
forest was a difficult problem so
immediately we end up with start well
and in some performance issues then we
when a personal count of the Google
cloud literally the first one was a
personal account is that to make
experiment then we the open-air
corporate account on that and basically
the story here to this first experiment
without the data just to understand out
how the cloud was working then we got
approval to upload some of our data in
the cloud officially as a company
contract and we are able to do this
experiment using a embarrassing amount
of factor because running the redemption
of the fund is a crazy amount of factors
using a tree and symbols to filter the
features and then fit in our networks
and the model we are building is time to
forecast a CDF that we can transform in
the PDF is telling to us the probability
or we are not forecasting that the size
of the redemption will be a very rich
guy second to that we have an to
forecast the probability of large flows
where large is a flow bigger than a
certain threshold so basic you take
advice on this 3d picture and then you
use that distribution to do your
forecast is a distribution conditioner
to all the input vectors this is the
only way we could have some decent
performance in this model no crazy big
but good performance something that you
can use in the daily life and was the
only way to do that now we are working
now in trying to make sense of this
model for day to day users because
interpretability another case that we
are working on I don't have to tell the
people in finance here that in
particular bonds traded over-the-counter
this data is unstructured and it is not
quantitative way to determine the
currents of the auditor course the
acosta are the big source of everybody
as included every vendor are using
because trade are very rare spares pass
dealer the information from dealer are
what people use to price this month and
as you saw before three different
provider
30 years in the market that you have a
severe disagreement of an easy bond okay
there is no way to the family
it's better or not a lot we have to rely
to subjected expertise of the traders
and there is one the reason I'm blacker
because I was in a company where there
was a big Italian desk because of the
amount of work the company has so I was
learning a lot I thought to be an expert
in pricing bond and then given the right
price to estimate liquidity I rise no
and I had to I learned a lot from our
traders so now how we transform this
know-how with ultimate eyes in the
strategies know-how so you should
remember not the benchmark price problem
now and then what we are trying to do
here is basically collect a wait
different pricing source and learning
how to wait this from feedback that we
received from the dealer dealer our
traders in the UI and trying to apply
NLP to that comment so nearly when it is
agree on the price they tell to us in
English why opening is better than my
one and and then we win NLP we try to
extract features to add adjust our model
we are the beginning of this journey but
this is Gustav was an IDI neck in
antenna back Roca Catalan of to my guys
last year and now we are trying to make
this a reality this is just introduced
what I think the same final answer that
I mentioned yesterday in the a spotlight
where I see the biggest improvements
impact of machine learning in finance
something that I am NOT expert so maybe
I'm shooting myself and keeping out me
out of the job that is NLP I'm a user
NLP and not building models in NLP but
if you think what is finance is
collecting data from the market
collecting for me information from the
provider and try to do what to forecast
people behavior so there is the
assumption that a volume of publish in
the market a trade that happened in in a
stock exchange
aerating the fact that the bond is the
sector on on this sector is something
that we enable you to forecast
behavioral to be able to market why
don't you go
source when you see people talking about
the market so doing NLP on text when you
okay thank you okay so basically guys if
you want me to stop you could have a
many less violent way to do to stop me
now I see the time here so was fine
anyway so before the call security kick
me out so this is the application in a
market some of them in Blackrock all
application landing page so people use
in NLP to apply their P to the
transcription of the company conference
call identify less abuse linkage between
stocks the similarity text base industry
classification and the last one what I
think is going to be a dramatic
revolutionary input in my modeling new
sentiment index for liquidity saw
somebody doing that doing this engine to
scribe test renews telling to me which
is the sentimental ability I'm pretty
sure I have no proof on this I'm pretty
sure that this feature will drive the
vast majority to the performance of the
model know so far nobody was able to
produce for me very high quality and a
sentiment on on liquidity but the
technology and the people are evolving
and I'm a big open NLP so to conclude
then I asked River seven eight six
minute or PNA this is a capping our
odorous likes a lot to this this picture
with this the cyborg man the robot
machine shaking the hands of the human
being that exactly the concept of pushy
for innovation black caucus is as well
as a big technology culture it's always
being pushy for innovation I'm getting
bored if I don't play with some things
in tools so we push for innovation but
in a non reckless way because we had the
problem of the fiduciary role to our
investors so it's always to find the
balance between performance of the model
and transparency interpretability
the motor survelliance that we are
observing is becoming more severe and
that is what we are the auto before us
really the infrastructure security
similarity NLP reinforced and transmen
learning are the thing we think we want
we are and we wanna investigate to see
if we can seek some performance in our
model so so be careful machine learning
is not the holy grain and we want to use
the only when add values we are able to
prove that there are already some cases
where we add in value we are rather in
the lab more to come
the bead push will be when there are
some there will be some interpretability
tools that then we you don't have any
problem to go while deep and try
everything you want I stopped here okay
so it's been a pleasure it's long
journey first time that italian finished
before the time the deadline so note
this as a big event and so thank you
very much for your attention is useful
[Music]